welcome to my series about city planning
and politics from a european perspective
we'll be following the history of the
fictional city of carpathia
located right on the civilizational
fault line of central eastern europe we
joined the story of carpathia at around
600 bc
the end of the iron age from which point
we'll be progressing towards modern
times
and as we go along we'll be discussing
relevant issues related to politics and
city planning
our story begins where most settlements
begin actually next to a river you know
since a source of fresh water is
absolutely fundamental for the
foundation of a human settlement
[Music]
so over here we have a small celtic
village springing up celts are actually
a major presence throughout ancient
europe including today's central eastern
europe now celtic society had a variety
of government structures including crude
election
systems this was called a tennis tree
and this word actually survives to this
day
in ireland the prime minister is called
tishek and the deputy prime minister is
called uh
toriste i think that's how you say it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
over here though in the village of uh
celt bathia
the government system resembles more to
a sort of warlord
king style leadership where we have
either one big tribe or multiple smaller
tribes united under one leader who then
basically goes around and extorts
tributes out of lesser tribes and this
kind of works for some time at least
because on the other side of the river
there is a new city being erected
or a camp rather by this somewhat known
entity called
the roman empire
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
uh
[Music]
and so let's talk about rome roman
civilization gets involved a lot today
mostly by far-right types and generally
speaking their idea of rome
is essentially muscular handsome white
people in togas solemnly staring into
the distance next to a bunch of columns
and they also consider rome as the sort
of four bearer slash
first instance of white civilization as
in you know rome was the first
purest expression of the greatness of
the white race a golden age of whiteness
which was then ruined by
decadence degeneracy and most
importantly
immigration at least that's the biggest
one usually
now you might be surprised to learn that
history is a bit more complicated than
that
for example the concept of race didn't
really exist back then
so when people today far writers mostly
say stuff like
the roman empire was a prime expression
of the white race's
ingenuity and superiority first off
race doesn't really make any historical
sense there and second
roman empire doesn't necessarily equal
roman civilization
for example the roman republic has
existed for twice as long as the united
states of america
so we are talking about enormous time
periods with their own distinct
history and politics where the empire is
just one of the many
but let's talk more about this idea that
roman civilization was
white you know we've all seen these
beautiful plain white marble statues of
antiquity
which are not so coincidentally a huge
part of modern
white supremacist iconography
in 2017 a history professor sarah e bond
dared to suggest that we should look at
classical heritage a bit differently
and so in her article why we need to
start seeing the classical world in
color
she posited that we should stop
fetishizing the blank snow-white marble
aesthetics of the ancient world because
a the statues were painted back in the
day and b
proclaiming whiteness as the standard of
beauty and culture
might just have some negative
consequences with regards to today's
race relations
and give some people some funny ideas
about race
now after she published this
level-headed and good faith article
the folks on the far right carefully
considered her points and published
counter essays
in order to challenge her ideas yeah i'm
joking of course they started sending
her death threats
but this idea of ancient roman culture
being this
stoic pure pearly white amalgamation of
whatever
is just not true you might be surprised
to learn because people back then
weren't categorized based on race the
concept of race did not make any sense
there was even a black roman emperor
called septimius severus
whose wife yulia domna was syrian and in
general inside the roman empire there
were lots of
ethiopians and black legionaries also
existed
so romans didn't really differentiate
themselves based on skin color
the main thing was citizenship if you
were a citizen you were held in higher
regard and you had certain rights and
had access to better public communities
and so the little celtic village that we
started with doesn't
exist anymore and that's because celts
were given roman citizenship
and so with time they largely integrated
into the roman empire became romanized
but also influenced roman culture a lot
and so the border city of aquingue would
continue growing
and would eventually become a regional
[Music]
center
[Music]
so
[Music]
we now have basic infrastructure such as
roads and a whole new city springs up
around the main fortified core
the city itself becomes part of the
roman frontier the
[Music]
limits
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the city itself existed and was
populated for a bit more than 400 years
and they even extended across the river
building a bridge in the process
and the fort of contra aquincom and so
both aquincum and contra aquinkum would
become the bases of the new settlements
that would form
after the departure of the romans which
would mostly happen by the end of the
4th century
and so this is the point where people
mostly far-right types come out of the
woodwork and say
aha the reason why the roman empire this
bastion of white civilization
fell is because all kinds of swarthy
people sort of swarmed its borders from
the east
and so the modern european union is the
roman empire and so we should keep
europe white by keeping out all the
refugees that try to come into europe
otherwise this is going to take over and
cause the fall of the european
civilization
just like they caused the fall of the
roman empire and
this view happens to be complete
horseshit for multiple reasons
well first off because of the
aforementioned white civilization thing
just not making any sense at the time
and the other thing is roman
civilization was heavily multi-ethnic
and multicultural
even the italian peninsula was heavily
multicultural and multiethnic
the entire history of rome is basically
either people showing up to its borders
and requesting entry
or rome showing up to other people and
assimilating them
or you know sometimes slaughtering them
so how come that the thing rome has been
doing for the entirety of its history
has suddenly become the facilitator of
its fall
well actually that's because rome could
not do the thing anymore
rome has lost the ability to assimilate
other people into itself
and how does that work well previously
when people showed up to the borders of
the empire they did so in hopes of
being able to take part in the empire
not in some esoteric way though
such as solemnly staring into the
distance while flexing their muscles and
looking solemn they wanted the tangible
benefits of the empire such as security
some level of infrastructure and overall
a better quality of life
and oh boy did the goths want it they
were being pursued by the huns
and when the huns start coming after you
i mean it's kind of like in resident
evil 2 when the tyrant starts chasing
you
if he ever catches up with you and you
decide to fight him then the only
question is how empty your clip will be
when you die
so in 376 a.d the gods start showing up
on the roman border
their goal is to cross the danube and
get accepted into the empire
thus the gothic forces combined with the
romans will be able to stave the hans of
with the help of the natural barrier
that is the danube
and here i'd like to actually make a
cultural note about how incoherent these
far-right flocks are when it comes to
the barbarians
you know gods were germans of
scandinavian origin
you would think that far righters would
be cranking their hogs over them you
know as the superior
white orions descending from the harsh
north
to deal the death blue to the decadent
decayed
parody of a civilization that is the
late roman empire
but instead these scandinavian germans
are viewed as the filthy barbarians and
the romans as the heroic white people
who fell against them
anyway coherence has never been part of
far-right ideologies
so in 376 the gods start appearing on
the roman border
not at akwing kung but on the lower
sections of the danube near the black
sea
over here actually in today's sylystra
in bulgaria fritigen had plans to
integrate the gods into the roman army
and when he got word that they have been
accepted to the roman empire as a
gesture of goodwill he converted himself
and everyone else to christianity
but then winter came and food rations
started running out
now the romans did send food aid to the
gods but they were basically stolen by
the local corrupt border officials
and they resold it to the gods at
exorbitant prices
and by the end it has gotten so bad that
the gods are basically pimping out their
women
and selling their children into slavery
just so they won't starve to death
and what they got for that is stuff like
dog meat
so of course eventually this led to an
armed rebellion which the romans
eventually did manage to crack down
but this was preceded by the 378th
battle of adrianople where the romans
got wrecked so hard that even emperor
velenz died in the battle
and he was described by historians as
pot-bellied and bow-legged and that he
had never been popular with the people
of constantinople who had suffered
through his purges of torture
public execution and banishment that
followed the civil war of the previous
decade
so you know he was a law and order type
so anyway the gods were eventually
beaten by the romans
including with the help of arabic
horsemen through the efforts of emperor
theodosius who
did his best to clean up his
predecessor's mess and theodosius did
actually manage to make peace with the
barbarian tribes
but this time entire regions were given
over to tribes themselves
so basically areas that nominally belong
to rome were entirely governed by
barbarians
and this was possible because the
barbarians could now negotiate with the
romans on much better terms than before
you know in light of just how much
trouble the gods caused the romans they
were no longer seen as this
indestructible unopposable force
and the romans themselves didn't want
another gothic situation either
so they were much more amicable to worse
terms even
so the combination of chaos upheaval
military defeat
and non-advantageous terms have together
led to the slow decline and then
ultimate collapse of the western roman
empire
and this entire chain reaction was
started by one
horribly mismanaged migrant crisis and
just imagine how things would have
turned out if the romans and the gods
combined their forces
in the meantime akunko eventually gets
deserted this is due to the general
upheaval and that the eastern parts
become more and more unsafe
and so virtually all inhabitants just
take what they can and move towards the
safer western lands
so now wakunku is empty and there's a
whole bunch of barbarian tribes roaming
about the area
including one very specific tribe or
rather a combination of seven different
tribes
and so the story will continue with the
founding of carpathia itself
this is going to be in episode 2 so
don't forget to tune in next time
in the meantime i've created a patreon
from my youtube channel
so if you want to support me monetarily
you can do it there if you feel like
this content is worth your money
thank you for watching and i'll be
seeing you next time